a card game using 36 unique cards for
suits diamonds hearts clubs and spades
this should be spades not spaces with
cards numbered from 1 tonight from 1 to
9 in each suit a hand is chosen a hand
is a collection of 9 cards which can be
sorted however the player chooses fair
enough
how many 9 card hands how many 9 card
hands are possible so let's think about
it there are 36 unique cards and I won't
worry about you know the others there's
9 numbers in each suit and therefore
suits 4 times 9 is 36 but let's just
think of the cards as being 1 through 36
and we're going to pick 9 of them so at
first we'll say well look I have nine
slots in my hand right 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
right I'm going to pick 9 cards for my
hand and so for the very first card how
many possible cards
can I pick from well there's 36 unique
cards so for that first slot there's 36
but then that's not part of my hand now
for the second slot how many will there
be left to pick from well I've already
picked one so there'll only be 35 to
pick from and then for the third slot 34
and then it just keeps going then 33 to
pick from 32 31 30 29 and 28 so you
might want to say that there are 36
times 35 times 34 times 33 times 32
times 31 times 30 times 29 times 28
possible hands now this would be true if
order mattered this would be true if
maybe you know I have card maybe I have
card 15 here maybe I have it let me put
it here maybe I have a 9 of Spades here
and then I have a bunch of cards and
maybe I have and that's one hand and
then I have another so then I have you
know cards 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 I have eight
other cards or maybe another hand as I
have the 8 cards 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and
then I have the 9 of spades
if we were thinking of these as two
different hands
because we have the exact same cards but
they're in different order then what I
just calculated would make a lot of
sense because we did it based on order
but they're telling us they're telling
us that that that the cars can be sorted
however the player chooses so order
doesn't matter so we're over counting
we're counting all of the different ways
that the same number of cards can be
arranged so in order to I guess not over
count we have to divide this by the ways
in which nine cards can be rearranged so
we have to divide this we have to divide
this by the way nine cards can be
rearranged so how many ways can nine
cards be rearranged if I have nine cards
and I'm going to pick one of nine to be
in the first slot well that means I have
nine ways to put something in the first
slot then in the second slot I have
eight ways of putting a card in the
second slot of because I took one to put
in the first so I have eight left
then seven then six then five taught
then four then three then two then one
that last slot there's only going to be
one card left to put in it so this
number right here where you take nine
times 8 times 7 times 6 times 5 times 4
times 3 times 2 times 1 or 9 you start
with 9 then you multiply it by every
number less than 9 every I guess we
could say natural number less than 9
this is called 9 factorial and you put
it you express it as an exclamation mark
so if we want to think about all of the
different ways that we can get we can
have all of the different combinations
for hands this is the number of hands if
we cared about the order but then we
want to divide by the number of ways we
can order things so that we don't over
count and this will be an answer and
this will be the correct answer now this
is a super SuperDuper large number let
me get let me just let's figure out how
large of a number this is we have let's
see 30 let me make sure I'm we have 36
let me scroll to the left a little bit
36 times 35 times 30 times 34 times 33
times 32 times 31 times 30 times 29
times 28
/ nine well I could do it this way I
could put a parenthesis divided by
parentheses 9 times 8 times 7 times 6
times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
now hopefully the calculator can handle
this and it gave us this number was at
94 million one hundred forty three
thousand two hundred and eighty let me
put this on the side so I can read it so
this number right here this number right
here gives us 94 million one hundred and
forty-three thousand one hundred and
forty-three thousand and two hundred and
eighty so that's the answer for this
problem that there are 94 million one
hundred forty-three thousand two hundred
eighty possible nine card hands in this
situation now we kind of just work
through it we reasoned our way through
it there is a formula for this that does
exactly the exact same thing and the way
that people denote this formulas they
say look we have 36 things we have 36
things and we are going to choose nine
of them right we don't care about order
so sometimes it'll be written as n
choose K and choose K let me write it
this way so what did we do here we have
36 things we chose nine so this
numerator over here this was 36
factorial but 36 factorial would go all
the way down to 27 26 25 it would just
keep going but we stopped only nine away
from 36 so this is 36 factorial so this
part right here that part right there
is not just 36 factorial it's 36
factorial divided by 36 minus 9
factorial what is 36 minus 9 it's 27 so
27 factorial so let's think about this
36 factorial it'd be 36 times 35 all you
keep going all the way times 28 times 27
all the way going all the way down to 1
that is 36 factorial 36 factorial now
what is 36 minus 9 factorial that's 27
factorial so if you divided by 27
factorial
27 factorial is 27 times
26 all the way down to one well this and
this are the exact same thing there's 27
times 26 so that and that would cancel
out so if you do 36 divided by 36 minus
9 factorial you just get the first I
guess the largest nine terms of 36
factorial which is exactly what we have
over there so that is that and then we
divided it by nine factorial and we
divided it by nine factorial and this
right here is called 36 choose nine and
sometimes you'll see this formula
written like this n choose K and they'll
write the formula as equal to n
factorial over n minus K factorial and
also in the denominator K factorial and
this is a general formula that if you
have n things and you're going to you
want to find out all of the all of the
possible possible ways you can pick K
things from those end things and you
don't care about the order all you care
is about which K things you pick you
don't care about the order in which you
pick those K things so that's what we
did here